gods don't always come from greatness I
mean the meditation of my tits are done
Oh Armada finally turned up right now
he's like no they aren't always born as
gods
some gods arrived from far away and no
one sees their ascension coming their
godhood even when no one else believes
they can Adam Armada Lindgren was born
on March 28 1993 and Gothenburg Sweden
Armada was born into a large family the
fifth of ten siblings and it was through
them that he discovered smash his older
brother Alexander any Olas Lindgren took
him to a local tournament in 2004 which
kicked off his love of competitive super
smash bros melee originally I served
playing smash 64
it was my older brother and Aeolus olds
my former teammate he borrowed smash to
four from a friend of his and we liked
the game so when Meili came out is there
natural for us to buy that game and we
play it in a casual way for a few years
and then an Eolas heard about an
upcoming tournament third a close to
where we live so he asked me if I want
to tag along and I've always loved
competing and I will always love melee
so that's pretty much how it all started
but while Armada did not succeed at
first he kept pushing two years later he
switched mains from Mars to peach and
started beating his local rivals I feel
like it started off pretty slowly at
first we were not that many players in
Sweden like tournaments it happened
roughly had like 30 people maybe
eventually a year one and a half year
and I climbed up to top ten but I said
it was not that many players to begin
with but then it went to a tournament in
early 2007 which was roughly two years
after my first tournament and going into
the tournament that was a mark made I
made mark for roughly one and a half
years
and I walked away from that tournament
as a pitchman because that tournament I
did end up having a few matches in a row
where it made more sense for me to play
peach I remember playing his IBP in
losers at some point and an Eolas
already played against him in pools and
beat him with his peach it was like yeah
Adam I think you should play your peach
instead of him or if I think that's
gonna be the right call but being a
local legend was not enough he wanted
more Armada attended Renaissance of
smash for the European national
tournaments he knew he wasn't strong
enough to win but he learned something
important there we always had like once
a year any sign of smash and it was like
basically like the European Championship
and that was coming up in July that year
so I had a few more months to practice
and I start to feel very confident I
kind of look at it like you know when
you have a puzzle and you've been
putting enough pieces together and it
all makes sense you know where to put
the next pieces that kind of wood it
felt like for me and Mellie it was like
I had enough of an understanding of the
game where each next step felt very like
much easier than before he took the
lessons he learned from Renaissance of
smash to hearts he kept working never
giving up Armada placed third at the EPI
to smash arena to Europe's biggest melee
tournament then he placed first at smash
attack which Armada won from the losers
bracket
Armada returned to France for a pita
smash arena 3 placing first again
beating AMSA once more while cementing
his place as Europe's best Smasher but
it was not enough Europe scene was
smaller than North America's and players
rarely traveled between regions to
compete in smash tournament's prize
pools were low especially in Europe and
few smash players could rely on melee as
a full-time job but North America was
where the best players were and Armada
wanted to prove that he was among the
game's elite going to the US was very
expensive and I actually ended up
borrowing like $1,000 for my
grandparents because I was like I want
to go to the US at least once because
melee was not in the strongest state
especially not in 2008 it had a very
rough period of time I was like you
never know how long the game is gonna be
around I want to be able to go at least
once
and before Genesis the best player in
Europe had never competed with the best
Americans so a lot of to us players
they're like oh no Armada he's not good
he's not gonna make top 30 - some people
thought I was gonna struggle in booths
but for me I was using all of these
words that's motivation I was like
alright now I'm gonna practice harder
and then when I perform well I can
literally say that you you and you
you're wrong at the time Genesis was the
largest melee tournament ever held and
the competition was fierce the era we
now know as the era of the five gods was
just beginning and almost every top
player was in attendance on his way to
the grand finals Armada brought down
lucky dishes Wiz mew2king and even
defeated mango America's best player in
the winners finals but mango was not
going down without a fight
he beat hungrybox in the losers finals
for another shot at Armada and he made
it count
playing that match oh he's like you know
pretty much singing along this song I
was like so relaxed I was like
regardless of what happens at this point
I know that I performed well Europe will
be proud I still obviously tried to win
but it was kind of a relief that now
I've proved myself enough so now I
should not feel as much pressure Armada
made Europe proud and remained
undefeated when he returned home but
every time he crossed the pond he
couldn't put together a first-place
finish
he placed 4th at pound for 2nd at Apex
2010 and second at pound 5 he was
winning everything in Europe but it was
not enough he was beating almost
everyone in North America but it was not
enough
he was second and it was still not
enough our motto returned to America for
Genesis 2 in July 2011 and beat bizarro
flame then s2 j and then ppmd hungrybox
and taj on his way to a faded Grand
Finals rematch with America's best
there's a really good storyline Genesis
to mango is kind of coming back to melee
again he had a period of time when he
played Mario Captain Falcon was not
really taking the game too seriously
more going to events to hang out with
people so it was a good storyline there
as well because I still hadn't managed
to win a super major in the US I got 2nd
multiple times and now mango is back as
well and then when dropping Grand Finals
again so I think a lot of people were
very happy about the rematch because we
hadn't played a single tournament match
against each other in those two years in
singles for the first time ever a
European Smasher took first place on
American soil for the first time ever
Armada defeated mango in the grand
finals for the first time in the US
Armada was not second
[Applause]
but still it was not enough our mana
kept winning and did not drop a single
tournament from Genesis in July 2011 to
Apex 2013 in January of 2013 Armada
became a god of melee but it gets lonely
on Mount Olympus
even though Armada kept winning even
though he was all but unstoppable melee
was stagnating back home our motto was
on his own and he was getting frustrated
just one week after winning a pax he
announced his retirement
it felt pointless after a while I was
like I had proven myself for a long
period of time like I think it was
number one for like one and a half year
or something and I won three super
majors back-to-back so it's basically
like I need to do this for six months to
get like two days of like enjoyment and
after a while I just didn't feel worth
it so I didn't stop playing nearly for
that year because I didn't like the game
it was just like I felt like it's not
worth it when I have no one to play
again while Armada was retired in Europe
smash was exploding in the u.s. in
February smashers won a charity donation
drive that got melee back into evo for
the first time since 2007 in October
Travis samox Beauchamp released the
smash brothers a documentary detailing
the history of melee up to that point
but Armada wasn't competing in European
tournaments he wasn't seriously testing
his mettle against America's finest
instead he was spending his time working
as a substitute teacher in Sweden a
teacher was sick they called man and I
was taking over his or her classes for
today
it was never anything I was planning to
do long term it was more like a
part-time job while I was trying to
figure out what I wanted to do with life
but then
no one quits merely entirely like no one
does so eventually I got you know
motivated to come back interest in melee
was at an all-time high and our mana
realized that it was finally time to
take the game seriously again our modest
still flew out to Evo and apex 2013 that
year he only played doubles at Apex 2013
but he placed fourth at Evo he was
floored by the outpouring of passion
from the community like when I stopped
playing melee I was number one in the
world for quite a while but when I came
back I kind of struggled for a while
partly like I barely played for a year
and everyone else got so much better I
had a lot of catching up to do for sure
and I was also going through depression
myself at the time so that combined with
all the pressure and expectations like I
feel like went a lot of other players
I've been coming back from a longer
break it's always been more of like
explanations for why but I feel like for
me for some reason it was never these
kind of things it was like the first
tournament I entered it was like a lot
of people expected me to like be back
it's number one immediately Armada
seriously returned to competitive melee
in time for beast 4 where he placed
second he traveled around Europe winning
tournament after tournament on his way
back to reclaim his throne but things
were more difficult than they seemed
2014 was a very bad year for me overall
to be honest your Avalon 3 singles melee
champion is none other
Ct EMP armadas returned to the US was
bumpy at first with a fourth place
finish at Skate r3 they saw him lose to
PPMD and mew2king but Armada righted the
course he beat m2k for first at
super-sweet then defeated him again at
super smash Sunday's lock-in
[Music]
at MLG Anaheim Armada faced off against
mango once again losing three to two in
the winners finals he made it back to
the grand finals but once again mango
brought him down at CEO 2014 mango and
Armada faced off in the grand finals yet
again but our mana came out on top
our bata is the champion of CEO 2014
only to fall to mango at King's of Cali
for a week later the next week
at Evo 2014 our mana didn't even get a
chance to play mango as he fell to
hungrybox in both the winter semi finals
and losers finals perhaps it was an omen
of things to come for the - but armadas
main rival was still mango our moderate
return to Europe defeated but he was
once again unstoppable on his home turf
his career had come full circle he was
the best in Europe but couldn't quite
make it past the last hoop stateside in
November 2014 Armada signed with
Alliance following a lower than usual
fourth place finish at big house for I
feel bad about that performance I am a
very very competitive person yes if I do
not place first that's not enough for me
yeah which second place is no good
that's no good which means fourth place
is horrible
then Armada fell to fifth at Paragon
Orlando his lowest placement since the
early days of his career Armada is out
from that point forward something
changed in Armada
whatever last piece of the puzzle was
missing he found it whatever training
needed doing he did it whatever he did
it was enough
[Applause]
Armada took second at Apex 2015 first at
MVG sandstorm second at CEO 2015 first
at Evo 2015 first at the big house five
first at Smash summit first at Genesis 3
and first at Smash summit - our motto
was without question the best melee
player in the world yet again when I won
evo 2015 my life overall was he so much
better I was in a much better place I've
been dating my girlfriend for five
months at the time as well and when I
start to feel better as a human being I
could see that in melee as well I
started to perform much better and once
i wouldíve oh it was also like a big
relief it was like I still can win super
majors and once I did that it was just
so much easier to like keep performing
well then came Evo 2016 our motto was
looking strong but hungrybox always a
step behind him shocked the world with a
grand finals reset and took an upset
victory on melees biggest stage
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah it was one of my absolute toughest
losses it's probably my second toughest
loss of all time next to pound five
actually but yeah it was very rough like
I wanted to also tie up the two Evo's
say I wanted to win that second Evo
title and also felt like I had it in the
bag which also makes it way harder to
lose if you lose a set very convincingly
Theo you might be disappointed that you
didn't play good enough and stuff but if
you lose 3-2 especially when you're up
in the final game it's it's much tougher
to accept that so yeah it was a very
emotional loss for me but hbox play
fantastic that day and he deserved it
and he probably wanted it even more than
I wanted especially since he got 2nd
twice in a row so yeah he earned that
one
but our motto bounced back first at
Canada Cup 2016 first at smash summit 3
first at Dreamhack winter 2016 first at
the UGC smash open first at Genesis 4
first at Beast 7 first at smash summit
again first at evil 2017 with plenty of
tournaments in between even make it back
by gauzy the repeat of world war 3 1
armada
winning evo 2017 from winners armadas
back half of 2017 has been difficult
hungrybox has caught up to the swedish
sniper and other top players started
figuring things out but our motto will
bounce back
he always has and he always will and
when he does someone will have to get
even better to beat him because for
armada ii is never enough thanks for
watching if you want more great content
be sure to hit that subscribe button